another thing that dr bright is not  allowed to do with the scp foundation  make up jodies for morning calisthenics  including of course the mickey mouse  clubhouse song in military parlance  jodies are a name for the chance  performed while marching to keep the  soldiers in time and boost morale these  can be extremely helpful for military  marches but not for the group  calisthenics being performed in the  foundation gym certain employees who  choose to remain anomalous in their hr  reports describe this as annoying and  distracting especially when dr bright  chose to sing the mickey mouse clubhouse  song dr cleff who did not wish to remain  anonymous said if i have to hear that  stupid song one more time when i'm  trying to get my morning reps in i'm  shoving that goofy medallion where the  sun don't shine  thank you dr cleff